В ефірі  «heute journal».
Добрий вечір.
«Прямуй за грошима» -
це старе правило,
яке здавна стимулювало
журналістів діставатися суті.
Фінансовий слід завжди вів
до найцікавішої,
найбільш приголомшливої та
найнесподіванішої інформації.
Візьмемо Саудівську Аравію:
країна імпортує
найбільше нафти з Росії.
Саме так: найбільший
експортер нафти у світі
сам купує «чорне золото»
у Володимира Путіна.
Російська нафта використовується
у країні для внутрішнього споживання,
тоді як власну нафту збуває
за рекордно високими цінами.
Про це свідчать офіційні дані
щодо експорту.
Ця ситуація суперечить
інтересам президента США.
Він терміново має вжити заходів
щодо завищених цін на нафту,
аби не втратити свій електорат.
Наразі переговорна позиція
президента у відносинах
із країнами Перської затоки
недостатньо стійка.
Бріджит Саар розповість більше.
Саміт Ради співробітництва арабських
країн Перської затоки у Джидді
став хорошою нагодою
для нафтових переговорів.
Переговори проходять радше ввічливо,
ніж результативно.
Зустріч із принцом Саудівської Аравії
була суперечливою -
Байден вимагав у
Мохаммеда бін Салману
спокутити провину за вбивство
журналіста Джамаля Хашоґджі.
Тепер президент США хоче знову
посилити співпрацю
із Саудівською Аравією
та іншими країнами регіону.
США прагнуть світлого майбутнього
для Близького Сходу.
Ми хочемо бути вашим партнером.
Ми не будемо відступати,
лишаючи по собі лакуну,
яку потім заповнить
Китай, Росія чи Іран.
Америка зацікавлена у встановленні
спільного лідерства
на основі стійких принципів
міжнародного права.
Але найтерміновішою потребою
Байдена є збільшення постачання нафти
з Саудівської Аравії,
що допоможе протистояти
енергетичній кризі та інфляції.
Однак досі кронпринц сказав лише про
готовність до збільшення потужностей.
Не було жодної обіцянки країн
Перської затоки щодо збільшення
постачання енергоносіїв на світовий
ринок чи безпосередньо до США.
Це питання домовилися обговорити
на наступному засіданні членів ОПЕК+.
Ідею створення нового альянсу,
здатного протистояти Ірану,
у Джидді сприйняли стримано.
Тож американському президенту
доведеться повертатися до Вашингтона
фактично без жодних
конкретних результатів.
Маємо називати речі своїми іменами:
Саудівська Аравія
заявила про готовність
«можливого» збільшення
виробничих потужностей.
Чи достатньо цієї обіцянки
Саудівської Аравії для Байдена,
щоб стримати світові ціни
на пальне?
Звичайно ж, цього недостатньо,
хоча можливо у наступні дні
через короткочасну ейфорію ми
спостерігатимемо
зниження цін на нафту.
Втім Джо Байдену доведеться чекати на
рішення країн-членів ОПЕК,
при цьому
він виглядає дуже впевненим.
Головною темою цього саміту,
звісно ж, були енергоносії:
що постачати і що закуповувати.
Декотрі вважають, що президент США
мав повернутися з каністрами нафти,
або принаймні із новою мирною угодою
між арабськими країнами та Ізраїлем.
Однак Білий Дім вимірює
ситуацію в інших масштабах.
Про це свідчать останні
візити президента.
Передусім йдеться про економічні
інтереси Сполучених Штатів,
проте Америка має і більшу мету:
протистояти Росії та Китаю.
Про це йшлося і на форумі
економік Тихоокеанського узбережжя,
і на саміті G7 у Німеччині,
і на саміті НАТО в Мадриді,
і на зустрічі в Джидді,
Завдання Байдена полягало
в позиціюванні США
як надійного партнера,
який пропонує конкретику.
Так, США ухвалили допомогу в
розширенні мобільних мереж 5G та 6G,
на яку водночас претендував Китай.
Вірогідно, зараз це більше
стосується США.
Ось, про що йдеться насправді:
інтереси таких країн не мають
суперечити західним демократіям,
натомість краще уникати співпраці
з тоталітарними режимами,
такими як, наприклад,
Росія та Китай.
Результати зустрічі в Джидді
не варто оцінювати барелями,
натомість повнішу картину зможемо
побачити лише за кілька місяців.
Дякуємо за такий
детальний аналіз, Ельмаре.
Цього літа ми маємо змогу зазирнути
в наше кліматичне майбутнє.
Останні новини не просто здивували,
а радше занепокоїли експертів.
Метеослужби попереджають про рекордну
спеку в Іспанії та Португалії.
У багатьох регіонах температура
перевищуватиме 40 градусів,
іноді сягаючи 44-градусної позначки.
До того ж очікуються сильні посухи.
Відомо про понад сто летальних
випадків через рекордну спеку.
Тим часом пожежні команди борються
з десятками лісових пожеж.
Камран Сафаріан розповість більше.
Уявіть, ви вирушили у кемпінг-тур до
курортного містечка Бібіоне в Італії,
як раптом на горизонті
з'являються клубки ядучого диму.
Відпочивальники шукають
порятунку у воді.
Згодом їх зможе врятувати
берегова охорона.
Спека та посуха вмить перетворили
райський куточок
на справжнісіньке пекло.
На іспанському курорті Коста-дель-Соль
відпочивальників теж приголомшила димова хмара.
Зараз Іспанія намагається
ліквідувати понад 30 лісових пожеж,
що лише посилюються через
40-градусну спеку.
Тисячі вимушені евакуюватися до сусідньої
Малаги через небезпеку поширення вогню.
Все, що в мене є, це мій будинок.
Я ледве встиг врятувати
своїх кота та собаку.
Та й усе.
Я дуже сподіваюся, що мій будинок
все ж вдасться врятувати.
Іспанія найбільше потерпає
від рекордної спеки.
У столиці країни, Мадриді, люди
охолоджуються як можуть.
Від спеки в Іспанії загинуло
щонайменше 360 людей.
Португалія теж повідомляє
про понад 200 загиблих.
Стовпчик термометра
перевищує 40 градусів.
Перехожі в Лісабоні
відчайдушно шукають затінку.
На Сході від Порту люди безпорадно
спостерігають за лісовими пожежами.
Пожежні літаки виконують небезпечні
маневри, аби загасити вогонь.
Один із пілотів сьогодні загинув
після падіння у гірській місцевості.
Через спеку Португалія
зазнає величезних збитків.
За тиждень пожежа поширилася на понад
25 000 гектарів землі.
Ця територія дорівнює близько
35 000 футбольних полів.
До неділі в країні оголошено
надзвичайний стан.
Звісно ж мені страшно,
але що я можу вдіяти?
Стрибнути у воду?
Я залишуся тут й чекатиму.
Спати точно не лягатиму.
На Атлантичному узбережжі Франції
теж пожежі.
Пожежна авіація працює безупинно.
Рятувальники мають евакуювати
більш ніж 12 000 людей.
Багато з них на межі виснаження.
Тим часом вогонь продовжує
ширитися Південною Європою.
Пекельне літо 2022 року.
Британська метеослужба також
попереджає про сильну спеку в Англії
наступного понеділка та вівторка.
Це перше подібне попередження в історії
Великої Британії.
Більше важливих новин
розповість Гундула.
Російська агресія
на Сході України посилюється.
Міністр оборони РФ Шойгу
наказав активізувати атаки
на всіх стратегічних напрямках.
Внаслідок ракетних ударів по Дніпру
троє людей загинуло,
15 зазнали тяжких поранень.
Росія знову стверджує
про нібито військову ціль.
Перевірити правдивість
такого твердження неможливо.
Попри енергетичну кризу,
спричинену війною в Україні,
канцлер Шольц прагне докласти
максимум зусиль для боротьби
зі змінами клімату.
Одним із кроків він вважає
сприяння видобутку
відновлювальних джерел енергії.
У своєму щотижневому зверненні
Шольц гірко визнав,
що через брутальний
напад Росії на Україну
Німеччина вимушена
використовувати електростанції,
які вже давно
виведені з експлуатації.
«Запізно!» - саме так відреагував
на відставку гендиректорки
виставки сучасного мистецтва
«documenta» Сабіне Шорман
уповноважений у боротьбі з
антисемітизмом федерального уряду.
Контракт із Шорман було
розірвано за згоди сторін
внаслідок скандалу на
всесвітній виставці мистецтв у Касселі.
Робота індонезійських художників
містила відверто антисемітські мотиви.
Спочатку проєкт завісили, а на
третій день виставки - демонтували.
Тепер офіційно:
польський футболіст Роберт Левандовський
залишає мюнхенську «Баварію»
та переходить до ФК «Барселона».
Вартість викупу склала
45 мільйонів євро
та 5 бонусних мільйонів.
Левандовський підписав
контракт на три роки.
А «Баварія» прощається
з 33-річним гравцем.
Перейдімо до виграшних
номерів лотереї.
Як завжди, без гарантій.
15, 17, 20, 22, 23, 26.
Суперчисло - 8.
Більше дізнавайтеся на сайті lotto.zdf.de
та в текстовій версії ZDF.
У понеділок рекордну спеку
відчують і в Німеччині.
Завтра температура коливатиметься
від 19 до 25 градусів,
на півночі та сході
буде хмарно і сухо.
В інших регіонах сонячно,
здебільшого безхмарно до 32 градусів.
Спека очікується у вівторок на заході:
стовпчик термометра сягне 40 градусів.
У середу незначну прохолоду забезпечать грози.
А ми повернемося вже завтра.
Дякуємо, що ви з нами.
Гарного перегляду
футбольного матчу. На все добре.
До зустрічі.